Okay, this person has stage 4 prostate cancer.
Please describe or paraphrase terms on your comments on blocking testosterone in IL6.
Okay, radiocologists that treat prostate cancer patients insist on using the energy and deprivation therapy.
So that's what blocks testosterone. Androgids are male hormones. They give it that way.
Testosteroid testosterone is an androgen.
So the theory is that testosterone increases the growth across the cancer.
It's based on the androgen receptor and cancer cells is highly competitive.
If the body need dihydro testosterone, we can block this receptor, the general positive response. Many kids patients have after beginning this.
It looks like you just copied and pasted this from their website or something.
There's research that shows that specific energy receptor AR3 is activated by testosterone, stimulating normal prostate growth in prostate cancer.
So we thought that testosterone over affects this receptor in a sense. However, somehow the receptors become hyper-reactive to testosterone, causate excess growth. This is called AR3 over expression.
It is thought that certain genes are become over expressed.
Okay, so it is. Okay, so this is using loop road or another energy deprivation therapy can dramatically reduce.
This is actually looks like it's from my blog.
So we've reduced PSA levels and even greatly slow cancer slow growth for a period of time. Then the cancer tends to reappear with the vengeance.
How can we address this? Okay, so that is a very true statement. Matter of fact, any honest oncologist will say that we'll talk to a person with prostate cancer and push them towards energy deprivation therapy will say that typically only works for about
three years and then the cancer can come back with their vengeance. So how can we address this? Well, it has been shown this that elevated interleukin six is a major mediator of this inflammatory response. So interleukin six.
So this gets back to your question.
Interleukin six is a what's called a cytokine. So there are certain chemicals that are made that are signaling chemicals in the in the immune response.
And these are different interleukins interleukin number six is a hyper inflammatory cell mediator chemical.
If we can reduce interleukin six, it can really help in many cases serves a purpose, but it can be overly it can be an over response and a laboratory response.
So decrease in interleukin six, anyway, that we can can be helpful.
So what are some things that can decrease interleukin six? Well, I think in my blog, which I really should update it, because at the time I wrote the by blog, it was in all the literature was really the only thing that really reduces interleukin six is EG CG, which is
the active ingredients of green tea extract. So green tea extract has a catacom called EG CG that has been shown in dozens and dozens of studies to decrease interleukin six levels.
There's been new studies that come out that resveratrol and even curcumin to some point, but resveratrol and EG CG from green tea extract are the two main components that can reduce interleukin six. So this is true, and I've talked to you about this that interleukin six is not is one of those inflammatory cytokines in brain inflammation in early dementia, Alzheimer's Parkinson's disease, etc.
So it's flavonoid that can be very beneficial for us. Also with people with prostate cancer patients, it's been shown that enter a graphis has been greatly beneficial to help with people that are doing energy deprivation therapy to prolong the effects, the positive effects of energy that deprivation therapy.
I will say there's new studies out on the energy deprivation therapy that are not positive. They're not positive that it actually you know prolongs the life of the patient and you know it might it's almost given that if you do energy deprivation therapy, you're brought your PSA is going to drop dramatically, you could have a PSA
them over a thousand started to start loop run and your PSA can drop to zero. It's dramatic, but there's some studies out that don't show that it actually decreases the progression of the disease. Just because it artificially drops your PSA doesn't mean it actually solving the problem PSA is just a marker.